yeah greetings everyone what a couple
things this is me mentally crumpling up
my notes of what my prepared remarks
which weren't very good anyway but after
conversations I had last night what I'm
hearing today I want to kind of switch
it up a little bit but before that I
like this kind of if you hear me once
clap your hands beating me twice clap
your hands because it always makes me
remind two things
early in my career I used to work with a
very experienced educator who used to go
like this look at my nose look at my
nose look at my nose and no one knew
what she was doing but everyone looked
at her nose and then she would just
start whatever which was amazing but
then also my very as my second my first
day and my first real job at the Florida
Aquarium in Tampa Florida I was a I had
to dress up as a fish my second day I
had to greet school children coming in
and my job was just to orient everyone
to where they're going and remind them
to behave etcetera etcetera they gave me
a bullhorn and then I watched nine
school buses pull up and I think it was
like no exaggerated slike 1,200 children
and they all kind of get off the bus and
they all kind of stand there and they're
excited and I'm just there with my
bullhorn like and this teacher comes up
to me says you need me to get him quiet
and I was like please and she just goes
resp ect and all the kids just stop and
go find out what it means to me and they
all sat down and I've never been able to
replicate that but we might try that
tonight at caveat um all right so my
name is Jonathan Frederick I work at the
University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
Moorhead planetarium and Science Center
is a science center on campus we pride
ourselves on being the Gateway to the
sciences we do a ton with like a lot of
you and I mean all of the work you do
with with not a lot but I don't want to
spend too much time about us I want to
talk about a few projects that we work
that may resin that we've created that
may resonate with what you're doing we
really believe that representation
matters and it sounds like that a lot of
you do as well which is great so through
our work with the North Carolina Science
Festival and what we do with our broader
impacts work we've launched a statewide
program called impacts which is mainly
we called it impacts kind of
passive-aggressively because everyone
was asking about our impacts we're just
gonna call the damn thing impacts and
we'll see what we do we have an external
evaluator but we
work with historically black colleges
and universities from around the state
we work with minority serving
institutions we work with companies
which is a little bit of a weak point in
our program where we're trying to get
more stem professionals who aren't on
college campuses involved and we
basically provide a short course where
they are trained in getting better at
science communication but what I like
about what we do is then we have they're
committed to being a part of at least
two of us and we pick events that are
most likely the kinds of events that
they're going to be doing in their
careers when they get asked to do
outreach so we have them go to a middle
school and share their love of what they
do and I totally echo Ben's sort of
hand-wringing about what if we just send
a scientist in there and they end there
they lay an egg and the kids are in the
audience like see I knew I didn't like
science so we want them to be good at it
but we still think it's worth doing
another event is a community style event
maybe an expo or some sort of family
gathering and what I like about that is
it's it's it's I don't if it's a safe
space but it's fun right and I think the
scientists find it really really
valuable nods are they gonna do some of
that work in the future but what we
found is that going to non science
advanced is even more fun than doing
kind of science Expos so we've been
partnering with music festivals barbecue
festivals a potato festival which I even
know that what that was it was it's
there's north eastern North Carolina has
a festival that is massive with Ferris
wheels and rides they set up overnight I
still don't know why people get on those
things we're built overnight but it's
packed and the potatoes are just because
they sell french fries and they're
really really popular so they have a
potato peeling competition and I ate
like 42 pounds of french fries and it
was great but our scientists had a great
time there but it's kind of interesting
and I may be the gorilla science UK
folks connect oh this context matters
co-creating matters and sort of building
community because we show up a little
bit out of context and it's kind of
jarring to the people who just came to a
potato festival to ride rides and have a
great time and then there's something
that seemed is sort of like schoolwork
maybe or a flash on science class
so we're thinking through all of these
ways to approach these events and one
program that I would really like to
share is about what we're doing with a
county in northeastern North Carolina so
my pre work I wrote it like 10 o'clock
at night and I was a little maybe a gin
and tonic and I'm not sure
but I was uh I was trying to sound
definitive about soft skills that I can
never feel a definitive about so I was
trying to like think of like really like
how do you get better doing science
outreach you just do it period send and
I don't really feel that way but I'm
scrapping a lot of because I think this
project is really important and one of
my take homes about what I was doing
with that pre work was that we make a
lot of these rules we can break them and
bend them and I think that's really
really important to remember
particularly when we're partnering with
with with people in meaningful ways and
so one of my rules and I'm reading right
now is I wish there were another picture
up there which would have my boss and
mentor who's in the audience and it
would be straight for me to talk about
this program because it's really her
brainchild so ladies and gentlemen
crystal Hardin so unexpected I know
right
how much time do I have where's my
fingers oh yes I got this okay
so you know one Jonathan put a little
context behind behind everything that
we're doing in Morehead representation
is very important to us so the impacts
program in our new project called the
signers Saunders science Scholars
program came about because Morehead is
really committed to representation and
we started a few years ago focusing on
diversity and inclusion in our entire
organization how does that look we
started not only with professional
development trainings for our staff but
we also implementing diversity
statements and diversity strategic
planning with our staff we have
trainings on implicit bias we do
actually culturally competent
assessments of our staff we have hiring
questions about diversity successes in
every interview from our undergraduate
students to our director level positions
so much so that our representation of
our staff has increased gone from 8%
into round two thousand eight or nine to
now over thirty three thirty five
percent in 2018 so we take it very
importantly we're starting with our
staff to create a culturally competent
workforce and environment also where our
staff feel safe talking about diversity
inclusion what does it look like and
we're always in the room asking the hard
questions
so this spreads over into our marketing
efforts
program design efforts and thus many of
the great programs that we're doing like
impacts are new I call them my babies
this is this is my I'm five years from
retirement so this last project is my
it's my baby because I'm gonna go off
into retirement after it's after I see
it to completion
it is a six-year project we're doing
with a rural county in North Carolina
earlier when people were talking about
bringing together your your funders and
what are your funders want and then your
community partners this is a full
collaboration of a funder who came to us
and said I love what you're doing here
in the Triangle but I want to give you
funding to replicate this in a rural
area and I have certain requirements I
won in a rural County I wanted to focus
on females particularly females of color
now it's private funding or state
organization with private funding I can
do that I do not break federal laws then
so then we had to find a partner so we
had great partnerships with certain
counties we went to a County and before
we even started planning I knew we had
to have the right partner at the table
for what we what I needed to undertake
went to a district very small district
only has five schools in the entire
county three Elementary School's one
middle school one high school and we
went to the district the assistant
superintendent superintendent were
merely on board with this idea of
creating a family Science Enrichment
Club mentoring ten families for six
years with monthly science club meetings
in the a child and a adult must attend
monthly science club meetings during the
summer we provide a one-week summer camp
also in addition to that all of our
other outreach opportunities we offer at
Morehead like the impacts program
scientists coming out our mobile
vehicles our science onstage programs we
would also pour those into the county so
we develop a partnership where we we
don't like the word adopting but it's a
full collaboration of all of our force
into one County the district came to the
table and we thought we knew what they
needed they came to the table and said
that's great but I really need you to do
this like we thought okay we'll give
these families iPads as you know they're
one year end of year celebration thought
it up whatever you want to call it the
district said and that's not gonna work
out
because many of our families don't have
internet access it's poor out here and
they can't afford it they'd rather have
their phone on than internet so okay so
that was out so we're now going with a
different idea we're gonna give them
drones it's out in the country all they
can do is fly drones there's space
everywhere we can do Sky Watch there's
no light blue there's nothing out there
so it's those kinds of things we sat
down with the partner and designed so
now we have this collaboration with the
partner they're fully on board then we
went to the school board the school
board they're fully on board because the
district is behind it
the school board is behind it now we
have the county manager and we have the
mayor on board because the district got
behind it we just finished our selection
process we thought we had ten families
we couldn't decide we'd end up with
twelve families and in the interview and
the interviews the families were talking
about the lack of resources this is a
county where it borders Virginia it's
kind of one of those Forgotten counties
and the lack of resources to science is
unbelievable one of the kickoff events
we did was a we took science to a Friday
night football game we just did a
science tailgate where we popped up with
our mobile vehicles people like we have
a university that has a drone aviation
trailer truck they pulled up at the
tailgate we have 4-h pull up at the
tailgate and as people were going into
the football game we're like hey let's
do some science and they were like hey
great so much so that everyone's asking
well are you coming to the next football
game that's not in the plan but we'll
figure that out but this is a full a
full collaboration we're going to follow
these children for six years my goal is
to our goal to impact this program is to
see them graduate and go on to college
and receive scholarships and all that
but we're gonna try to track them
through high school to hopefully see
them enroll in higher education science
courses and we're - how are we doing
that we talked about metrics so we're
doing research and evaluation two very
separate things we're evaluating each
event that we're doing but then we are
researching how are we what's the impact
of this program how is it impacting the
science identity of these group
that we're studying we're studying a
rule we're studying females and we're
studying african-american females and so
we have metrics set up between
quantitative data such as their scores
to qualitative data with studies of
their interests and attitudes through
various various validated metrics that
we're using to study impact over the
next six years this is a model that
other districts are already trying to
figure out how can we do this in our in
our district if this if this works it
will be a model for North Carolina it
just go to work it's got to work but
that's what it is okay and I think I'm
done
[Applause]
you